so in this video we're going to revisit
another super simple economy that only
has a farmer and a builder on an island
and we're going to review what we
learned about the multiplier and the
marginal propensity to consume but we're
going to do it a little bit more
abstractly so just as a bit of a review
the marginal propensity to consume this
is a number usually between 0 and 1 that
says if you were to get an extra dollar
how much of that would you spend and so
your marginal propensity to consume if
it is 0.25
that means that if you were to get a
dollar you would spend 25 cents of it if
your marginal propensity to consume is
0.6 that means that if you were to get a
thousand dollars you would spend six
tenths of it you would spend 600
and so
using this idea and i'm going to keep it
abstract let's just say that we start
with the farmer she spends x dollars on
products or services from the builder
so x dollars goes to the builder
now what's the builder going to do and
we talked about this in the previous
video the builder is going to say i have
x dollars we're going to assume everyone
on this island has the same marginal
propensity to consume he's now going to
spend some of it and he only has one
place to spend it it's a very simple
economy what's he going to spend
well he's going to spend x times the
marginal propensity to consume if this
seems very abstract think about it if x
was a thousand dollars and if the
marginal propensity to consume is let's
say 25 hundredths or 0.25 now he's going
to spend 1 000 times 0.25 which would be
but now all of a sudden the farmer has
this much money and what's she going to
do well she's going to she's going to
spend this times the marginal propensity
to consume
so she is now going to spend
x times the marginal propensity to
consume which is how much she got from
the builder and how much of that is she
going to spend well that times the
marginal propensity to consume again so
it'd be the marginal propensity to
consume squared and then this just keeps
going on and on and on
and so he's going to get this amount
what's he going to spend well he's going
to spend that
times the marginal propensity to consume
again so it's going to be that and we
could just keep going on and on and on
but if we want to figure out how much
increased output is there in this
economy because of that initial
expenditure of x dollars
well you would just sum everything up it
would be
x plus x times the marginal propensity
to consume
plus x times the marginal propensity to
consume squared goes on and on and on if
we want we can factor out an x so x
times one plus
marginal propensity to consume plus
marginal propensity consume squared on
and on and on and you might recognize
from your algebra class or maybe your
precalculus class that this is an
infinite geometric series that we cover
in other videos and you can actually sum
this up it's one of the cooler things in
mathematics
this can be summed up as being equal to
1 over 1 minus the marginal propensity
to consume
and so you have that initial expenditure
of x but the total amount of output is x
times this expression and so that's why
this expression right over here is known
as the multiplier if the farmer spent
one dollar initially on the builder well
it's going to be one dollar times this
expression in terms of how much
increased output there is in the
simplified economy so this is the
multiplier
now let's do something interesting and
something new that we hadn't done before
let's imagine that somehow some magic
government shows up on this island and
decides to tax the farmer just says hey
we're just going to take some money from
this farmer for for whatever it might be
and so this magic government the amount
that they take away we will call that
delta t you could sometimes do that as
your change in taxes so this is positive
that means that the government is
getting money and money is being taken
away from the farmer
so what's going to be what's the farmer
going to do
well from the farmer's point of view
they she now has
the delta t less dollars and so that's
going to affect her consumption it's
going to decrease her consumption how
much is it going to decrease her
consumption by what's going to be the
amount she has to give to the government
times her marginal propensity to consume
times the marginal propensity to groom
why does this make sense well in the
situation where if i give the farmer a
dollar let's say the marginal propensity
to consume is is 0.5 if i gave her a
dollar she would spend 50 cents if i
took a dollar away from her she would
spend 50 cents less the amount i take
away times the marginal propensity to
consume
but if this is the effect on the farmer
what's going to be the total effect on
output
well this is the situation where
essentially x is equal to that if i take
away delta t from the farmer that's
essentially saying x is equal to this
thing right over here
so x is equal to this thing right over
here and so what's going to be the
impact well the total output is going to
be equal to x which is
negative
delta t
times the marginal propensity to consume
marginal propensity to consume that part
right over here that is that
times this times the multiplier times 1
over 1 minus the marginal propensity to
consume
or if you want to express this
multiplier as something multiplying by
that increase in taxes
this would be equal to
delta t
times the negative
of your marginal propensity to consume
over 1 minus the marginal propensity to
consume and so this expression which
seems all fancy and technical but all
it's doing is saying all right look
if you take money away from the farmer
this would be the effect on her initial
spend and so then you get this
multiplier on the taxes and this
negative is is because it if you have an
if you have a positive taxation right
over here it would have a decrease in
output because of the multiplier
and some of you might have seen
something where the denominator looks
different you might see something called
a mps or marginal propensity to save and
that just comes out of the simple idea
that if i have let's say that i have a
marginal propensity to consume of
0.3
well that means for every dollar i get
i'm going to spend 30 cents of it well
how much am i going to save
well if i spend 30 cents i'm going to
save the rest so my marginal propensity
to save in this situation would be
70 cents or another way of thinking
about it your marginal propensity to
consume plus your marginal propensity to
save is equal to one or another way of
thinking about it subtract the marginal
propensity to consume from both sides
your marginal propensity to save is
equal to one minus your marginal
propensity to consume
and so that's why
this thing is the exact same thing as
this thing and so sometimes you might
see a formula for the tax multiplier let
me write this down tax
multiplier
tax multiplier that looks like this
where they write the negative of the
marginal propensity to consume over
instead of 1 minus the marginal
propensity to consume they write the
marginal propensity to save
and when you're learning this in
economics it all seems so cryptic where
did this come from mps npc people try to
memorize these things but as you can see
it's coming out of reasonably
straightforward algebra economists
sometimes have a knack for for making
straightforward algebra seem a little
bit more complicated than it needs to in
the next video i'll do some worked
examples so that we can actually apply
these formulas to see and see that it
makes sense